[Music]
the cult Netflix series stranger things
is back and darker than ever the last
series was set in 1984 but this one
jumps forward to 1985 following a group
of now young adults seasons 1 & 2 were
filled with great 80s references we're
gonna have a look at all the ones in
season 3 and yes
spoilers are coming a beauty a jock a
rebel 1985 was a strong year for cult
cinema box-office hits included The
Goonies Brazil and Teen Wolf so we
expected some strong cultural references
from season 3 the most obvious one is
Robert's Mex is back the future this
features obviously in Episode seven were
dusted in his group hide in screening of
the movie to escape the Soviets first we
see a poster then segments of the movie
playing on the projector but did you
spot an earlier reference in mrs.
Driscoll's house in episode 2 the camera
pans from a KitKat plot on the wall to
Nancy and Jonathan that clock is in the
title sequence for Back to the Future as
well as in Katy Perry and Taylor Swift
music videos there are also some visual
parallels between choice visiting mr.
Clark in his garage with Marty visiting
doc there's been a poster for the thing
on the wheelers basement wall since
season 1 but the movie gets a name check
this season by Mike and Lucas in episode
3 in episode 1 the gang sneak into a
screening of George Romero's Day of the
Dead it's billed as a sneak preview as a
movie premiered on June the 30th 1985 I
had a widespread release on July the
19th so the Hawkins middle AV Club
really would have been some of the first
people to watch it we also see a poster
further Evil Dead on Jonathan's bedroom
wall in this episode originating from
1981 fans will be keeping a close eye
out for the it Easter egg in season 2
Bob Newby's childhood story seemed to
recall the of
of Stephen King's it in season 3 episode
7 Alexei is shot in the fairground by
Grigory at the same time a red balloon
is pop by someone winning a prize the
book it didn't come out until 1986 could
the red balloon pot be a nod to it
the series makes heavy reference to the
Goonies
Dustin also near repeats one of the most
famous lines in the film when arriving
at the bottom of the elevator in episode
5 interestingly the Goonies and stranger
things both starred Sean Astin who
played Bob Newby in season 2 and appears
in a brief season 3 flashback the Soviet
threat in season 3 brings up some
interesting parallels with eighties cold
war movies the opening scenes resembled
that of 1983 s war game in episode 5
Dustin recalls the movie Red Dawn in
which a group of teenagers attempt to
defend their town from a Russian
invasion in episode 3 Dustin mentions to
Steve that they're likely to spot an
undercover Soviet because he's carrying
a duffel bag and he sort of got a point
name any big action movie from the mid
80s and this trope comes up
Rambo first blood to saudi 'it's a view
to a kill the soviets rocky fool Dolph
Lundgren as the Soviet the plotline of
Soviets taking over a shopping mall has
parallels to Chuck Norrises 1985 film
invasion USA in which the action star
takes on a mixture of Latin American and
Soviet agents in Episode five when one
of the Soviets shoots at Joyce at hopper
he follows the car out into the garden
in a robotic way the scene looks very
similar to the end of the copshop
shootout in the Terminator the mayor in
Episode four even makes a joke about
when bad guys being honored
Schwarzenegger
in Episode five is the most obvious
die-hard reference hopper holds a gun to
Gregory's head
Grigoriy says that hopper won't dare
shoot him because policemen have wounds
an exact quote a henchman says to John
McClane with the same spray of
machine-gun fire after something more
subtle perhaps is dusting getting stuck
at the air vent in Episode four mid 80s
horror fans will love the funhouse
sequence in episode 7
when Hopper enters you can hear a
taunting spooky voice say do you dare
face the challenge of the funhouse it
sounds eerily like the trailer voiceover
from 1981 s funhouse a horror film set
at the fair the Hall of Mirrors moment
plays out like the 1983 fantasy
Something Wicked This Way Comes also set
at the fairground the mind flayer seeps
and oozes into host bodies much like
help the blob moves around in the 1988
movie the way it hugs onto its victim
face is similar as well as it's very
sticky tendrils and that creepy hospital
scene in episode 5 it has a bit of a
Halloween - feeling about it
episode 6 features of rather gruesome
scene where Stephen Robin are being
interrogated by the Russians torture
equipment is brought in along with an
administrator in a white overall
personally this reminded me of the
torture scene in a 1985 terry gilliam
film brazil in episode 8 Billy's car
lights flash on as he prepares to smash
into Jonathan and Nancy these shots look
very similar to the 1983 horror film
Christine about a man possessed by his
car also when he enters the mall Billy
appears to be dressed like Kurt Russell
in 1986 Big Trouble in Little China
in the same episode Steve and Robin are
in the video rental store but we can see
lots of posters and front covers of VHS
tapes
there's Mad Max Animal House car wash as
well as a poster in the window for 1984
Scarface Steve knocks over a cardboard
cutout to 1982's Fast Times at Ridgemont
High which in itself is a very rich
monetized slapstick thing to do we
couldn't talk about movies without
mentioning the neverending story in
episode 8
Dustin cause his girlfriend Suzie to ask
what Planck's constant is in order to
unlock a door she forces him to serenade
her with the theme tune to the
neverending story it was released in
April 1985 so it would have been a
current cinema movie also note how on
the wall of Susie's bedroom she has a
poster for The Wizard of Oz another
escapist fantasy she's reading The
Wizard of Earthsea
by Ursula Le Guin two popular 80s TV
shows feature in this season in episode
one hopper is watching magnum p.i a show
about a charismatic private investigator
there's also a short snippet of Cheers
when Joyce is eating a TV dinner alone
she thinks about Bob commenting on the
will they won't they story line between
the characters of Ted and Diane could
this be a parallel to Joyce and hospices
will they wrote they sexual tension the
shopping mall was a central part of
American life in the 80s jazz royal
explained in stranger things world's
turned upside down that the production
wanted to stay true to all the products
on sale so actually built a mall as the
set genuinely filled with products
classic 1980s US brands are in stitching
there's the gap JC Penney Gordon Brooks
Sam Goody and we told that Taco Bell and
a spirit are coming soon best the book
breaking with Moscow behind Steve and
Dustin in this season 3 episode 3 scene
this is a genuine 1985 release by a
former Soviet foreign minister it
foreshadows and Lexi's storyline in
episode ones first scene of the credits
the camera pans over to cassettes one is
by Bryan Adams and the other one is by
Corey Hart very much the 1983-84
heartthrob it's also in this episode
that we see music posters on Jonathan's
bedroom wall
there's one for REM specifically their
1983 release murmur even though the band
was formed in 1980 they didn't achieve
vast popularity until 1987 which means
Jonathan caught them in their cult
period 80s era music fills the season we
catch parts of Madonna's Material Girl
REO speedwagon's can't fight this
feeling the cars moving in stereo
foreigners cold as ice and Bonnie
Tyler's total eclipse of the heart
the season has noticeable product
placement of Coca Cola specifically New
Coke which was a limited-edition run in
1985 Netflix executives even visited the
Atlanta Coca Cola archives to study the
packaging and advertising look closer at
some of the books and magazine covers
throughout the season in episode one
mrs. wheeler is sat poolside reading
Johanna Lindsay's Tender is the storm a
sensation this romance novel from 1985
she also reads a book by the same author
in season 2 episode 9 in episode 3 Matt
shows 11 a copy of super team featuring
a double page spread of Ralph Macchio
The Karate Kid which came out in 1984 in
Max's bedroom we see a poster for the
1960s cult surf film the endless summer
the poster reads follow the surf around
the world from Malibu which potentially
foreshadows later surfing scenes in
California with Billy the additions of
Penthouse magazine that Alex and 11
discovering Billy's drawer in episode 3
our genuine historical additions in
episode 4 max is also reading mid-80s
editions of Wonder Woman and Green
Lantern in episode 7 the group Lutz a
store now it's the same store that 11
stole from in season 1 this time she
sits in front of a fridge full of Eggo
waffles preparing to enter the upside
down in previous seasons we have seen
her go straight to grab them but in
season 3 the situation at the ball is so
desperate that she barely even looks at
them it Mike's basement we see retro
ball games like upwards which was
invented in 1981 I don't know about you
but Dustin's toys coming to life
reminds me of the front cover of Stephen
King's 1985 collection skeleton crew the
cover features a simple crapping monkey
will appears in his wizard costume for
the first time during Dungeons & Dragons
and it's a dead-on match with the
drawings of will the wise that we saw on
the wall in season 2 episode 4 the
funfair scene gives us two 80s
references the first is to ride the
Gravitron a popular ride introduced in
1983 and a stuffed toy Alexei wins of
Woody Woodpecker who is a kids TV staple
in the mid 80s think you spotted
anything not on this list comment below